regardons lunettes potins on les enlève
quoi on les a guère qu'un en voltige
un laser qui libère autant d'énergie que
toute la production mondiale
d'électricité
de quoi impressionner ces jeunes
étudiants en science du secondaire qui
visitent de vrai laboratoire pour la
première fois ça intéressant c'est que
j'aime beaucoup le fait que en plus à
prendre la matière les plus petites
particules la vitesse c'est vraiment
tout ce qui est physique chimie est
vraiment intéressant l'institut national
de la recherche scientifique accueille
normalement des étudiants à la maîtrise
ou au doctorat
mais il veut aussi stimuler l'intérêt
des jeunes qui sont encore plusieurs
années de leurs études supérieures
oui sont loin mais je me dis toujours
dans 3 4 1 ils vont être certains
d'entre eux vont aller à l'université
donc c'est une façon de se faire
connaître dans notre milieu sur 180
étudiants je pense que semble qu'ils
sont même si en os 4 5 6 qui reviennent
bien ce sera déjà ça
les électrons on l'utilisé les photons
mais il faut parfois coupé les cheveux
en plusieurs millions pour les stimuler
besoin d'être beaucoup ce qu'on va faire
maintenant c'est regarder le cheveu ce
qui est dans mozilla d'unique on appelle
ça le les tablettes le nano mal de voir
comment mon cheveu était l'enfant en
plus qu'ils sont sains c'est vraiment de
la technologie haute et qu'on voit
pénaliser l'industrie c'est juste ici
que c'est vraiment très impressionnant
même
c'est à base de séances aujourd'hui je
montre aux étudiants la similarité entre
la cuisine moléculaire et les systèmes
de délivrance des médicaments
donc comment on peut appliquer la
science et les réactions chimiques dans
notre cuisine ces jeunes élus mais on
feint de savoir mais parfois aussi ils
ont tout simplement fait ici le monsieur
marc sonné radio canada va régner